وان كانت الشهاده يعني
[موسيقى]
نريد ان يكون الى جانب اطفالها يعني كل
يوم يكبرون والعائله كبرت
[موسيقى]
نرى الفرحة الفلسطينيه العارمه المتدفقه
والالم والامل الفلسطيني نحن حريه كل
الاسرى باذن الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
عدنان هو
معتقل في السجود الايطاليه منذ الخامس من
شهر فبراير شباطا الماضي اعلنت عن اضرابه
عن الطعام فور اعتقاله من منزله في بلده
عرابه في جنين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مجرد عزمي على اضراب يكون قد كسرنا الرهبه
التي وضعوها في صدورك كاسرى بعد اخفاء
اضراب حول 100 اسير اداري المره الاولى
انفصل خضر عدنان على الدوله اذا لم ينجح
في المره الثانيه ستكون دوله اتصلت على
فرد مساله
اختلاف كبير بين الثنتين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رجلا مضربا عن الطعام منذ اكثر من ثمانين
يوما لم يتلقى اي مداعمات ليبقى داخل
زنزانه يفقد الوعي داخل زنزانه بدون اي
مرافقه طبيه بدون ان يكون حتى على سرير في
احد المستشفيات خضر عدنان وجد فاقدا للوعي
داخل زنزانه في سجون الاحتلال وداخل
زنزانه انفراديه
[موسيقى]